allez on va parler de l'Ukraine et de la
guerre qui a 500 jours un peu plus même
aujourd'hui votre livre l'ours et le
renard chez Perrin revient sur cette
guerre sur l'armée ukrainienne qui a
finalement résisté mais qui a subi aussi
beaucoup de pertes une guerre de
position plus une guerre de mouvement
vous allez nous expliquer pourquoi c'est
votre lecture en tout cas premier champ
de bataille beaucoup plus transparent
que les précédents regardez c'est dans
l'invitation d'Hélène Bonduelle on en
parle ensemble juste après
si on vous invite Michel Goya c'est
qu'au moment où l'OTAN réunit pendant
deux jours à Vilnius s'apprête à
réévaluer l'aide militaire à l'Ukraine
vous signez un récit unique sur cette
guerre autour d'un dialogue minutieux
avec l'historien Jean Lopez vous publiez
l'ours et le renard histoire immédiate
de la guerre en Ukraine pendant huit
mois vous avez échangé vos impressions
vos analyses sur cette guerre et un
premier constat assumer l'aveuglement
occidental le vôtre aussi sur cette
décision incongrue de la Russie
d'attaquer l'Ukraine il y a toujours de
bonne guerre de Thabor de montrer ses
muscles pour essayer d'obtenir un
résultat politique sans faire la guerre
on a pensé qu'on était dans ce scénario
on s'est trompé une bonne stratégie elle
doit associer un objectif réaliste et
des moyens adaptés et là très clairement
il manquait l'un et l'autre à la Russie
Michel Goya ancien officier des troupes
de Marines vous êtes historiens
spécialiste de la guerre auteur d'une
quinzaine d'ouvrages sur le sujet
que s'est-il réellement passé dans le
don-basse à Cardiff sur les rives de la
Mer Noire ou dans l'attaque des deux
gazeux duc qu'en est-il de la
contre-offensive ukrainienne tant
annoncé après plus de 500 jours de
combat chacun campe sur ses positions
Poutine ne veut rien lâcher quand elle
inscrivent tout reprendre
[Musique]
alors Michel Goya nous avons une
question
au moment où nous franchissons un
nouveau cap dans l'aide militaire
l'Ukraine a-t-elle les moyens matériels
et stratégiques de gagner la guerre
réponse oui oui mais il faudrait d'abord
savoir ce que signifie gagner la guerre
reprendre le don-basse reprendre même la
Crimée ce scénario là est-ce que il est
possible ça c'est l'objectif
effectivement c'est l'objectif
stratégique affiché actuellement par
l'Ukraine ça pas toujours été le cas
initialement au début du conflit au
début de l'invasion en tout cas le
premier objectif c'était simplement
survivre puis ensuite éventuellement
repousser les Russes sur la ligne de
départ sur les déjà suffi pour peut-être
on en est plus là maintenant ukrainien
veulent tout récupérer
ils sont pour l'instant c'est encore
possible c'est encore possible oui c'est
encore possible et ce qui va se passer
dans les semaines et les mois qui
viennent sont sans doute déterminants
pour savoir si réellement c'est possible
alors on va regarder la carte c'est
celle du conflit aujourd'hui la
blitzkriek de Poutine n'a pas eu lieu
l'armée russe s'est repliée sur le don
de base mais a repris baroute et les
Ukrainiens ont repris une bonne partie
du Nord et une partie du Sud du se passe
on va pas vous connaissez ça mieux que
moi notamment Carson pourquoi vous dites
finalement quand on voit quand même des
mouvements que c'est une guerre de
position parce que il y a eu mes futurs
énormément de mouvements pendant le
premier mois de guerre il y a eu toute
l'invasion du sud du pays par les Russes
qui a été assez facile sur leur grande
victoire en réalité toutes les provinces
de Carson et une partie la province de
saporoca dans le Nord cette tentative en
revanche a complètement échoué autour de
Kiev il y a une immense bataille toute
cette bataille oui enfin de Cardiff
jusqu'à Kiev c'est quasiment tout le
nord de la France quoi dans le terme en
convention cette bataille a été perdue
par les Russes ils ont été obligés de se
replier et à partir du mois d'avril on
s'aperçoit que les choses se sont fixées
et on est cette guerre de mouvement avec
beaucoup de mouvements effectivement
c'est transformé en garde de position ce
qui est un phénomène assez classique en
réalité les guerres modernes sont très
meurtrières et si on s'impose pas enfin
s'il y a un camp qui ne s'impose pas
tout de suite
qui arrive assez fréquemment quelques
semaines quelques mois cette guerre a
tendance à se prolonger tout le monde
s'enterre en se fortifie et ça devient
une garde position qui est le durée des
années alors on va parler des deux
armées force et faiblesses de l'armée
russe de Poutine vous parlez d'une armée
soviétique classique complètement
surestimé par le chef du Kremlin
pas que par le chef du Kremlin mais vous
savez c'est très difficile de savoir
comment va se comporter une armée
lorsque commence une guerre
c'est comme si vous allez estimer quel
sera le résultat d'un match de foot
alors que vous ayez les équipes n'ont
pas le droit de jouer avant donc vous
dites voilà dans deux ans il s'est deux
équipes vont jouer l'une contre l'autre
surestimée par tout le monde en fait et
donc oui c'est assez classique aussi les
Russes sont quand même aussi assez forts
pour présenter toujours une enfin ses
inventeurs du concept de village
potenkins donc toujours présenté une
face brillante ou puissante et puis
derrière c'est souvent plus
comment dire c'est beaucoup
moins brillant justement et là oui c'est
cette armée était
beaucoup de progrès c'est une armée
puissante c'est une force complète
c'est le plus grand arme enfin la plus
grande force nucléaire du monde en terme
de nombre de têtes nucléaires c'est une
aviation puissante c'est une armée qui
va dans l'espace c'est
etc mais mais c'est un peu c'était
effectivement un peu une armée potamine
c'est une armée qui a réussi aussi un
certain nombre de choses la guerre 2014
2015 dans lequel elle est intervenue
cette terre merus a été une victoire
finalement pour eux l'intervention en
Syrie militairement c'est plutôt c'était
plutôt bien fait donc on avait vraiment
cette cette impression d'une armée voilà
vraiment puissante plus puissante en
tout cas que celle de l'Ukraine qui
donnait plutôt des indices initialement
des indices plutôt contraire
aujourd'hui cette armée là elle peut se
passer des 26000 hommes de Wagner depuis
le putsch manqué est-ce qu'elle peut en
l'état
sans ces hommes qui sont partis depuis
cette mutinerie avortée alors 26000 sur
il doit y avoir 36000 combattants russes
et séparatistes en Ukraine donc
quantitativement c'est pas très
important mais en même temps c'est
malgré tout on va dire c'était une
troupe d'élite une troupe
incontestablement dont il faut rappeler
que c'était pas forcément le premier
métier Wagner c'est normalement été
inventé pour aller justement là où ne
veut pas on ne veut pas envoyer l'armée
russe pour maintenir les choses dans ce
qu'on appelle du déni plausible dire bah
c'est Wagner c'est pas nous etc donc
particulièrement dans le théâtre
extérieur en Syrie d'abord échappé
complètement se retrouver voilà cette
armée parce qu'il y a il fallait faire
feu de tout bois on a été utilisé dans
dans cette guerre et puis et puis elle
est devenue un monstre et c'est un petit
peu il peut faire ça parce que on sent
que le nombre de choses depuis cette
mutinerie alors certains disent ou
d'état ou tentatives de coup d'État ou
de elle est encore là elle se
propage encore même aussi précoji n'est
plus là même si on ne sait plus où il
est exactement on voit bien que la
rancoeur des nationalistes et là ceux
qui critiquent encore Shugo le ministre
de la Défense qui disent au fond cette
fameuse opération spéciale on la défense
mais on l'a fait mal et ça c'est encore
en Russie et ça ça fait mal non oui bien
sûr dans une guerre fin d'abord ce ne
sont pas les armées qui feront les
guerres ce sont les nations la force
d'une nation c'est effectivement c'est
son armée qui est devant là-bas mais
aussi toute l'arrière l'arrière de la
société et le fonctionnement de l'État
des deux côtés de côté craignant on a
une nation en arme qui est très
déterminée qui est solide et du côté
russe c'est un peu plus compliqué on a
beaucoup moins impliqué la nationalité
dans la dans cette guerre il y a pas une
mobilisation générale comme il y a eu en
Ukraine en partie parce que certainement
le pouvoir se méfie justement peut de sa
propre société
plus profond mais se méfie aussi de ces
organes de sécurité c'est à dire que la
société enfin l'État c'est devenu il n'y
a plus de monopole de l'emploi la force
légitime mais plutôt une oligopole avec
tout un comment dire l'oligarchie de la
société l'oligarchie économique a donné
naissance aussi à une oligarchie de
sécurité avec des champs des gens qui
peuvent aussi menacer directement le
pouvoir force et faiblesse de l'armée
ukrainienne comment vous jugez cette
contre-offensive
ukrainienne qui est allée jusque en
territoire russe ça a été très
symbolique même si c'est symbolique
est-ce que est-ce qu'elle est efficace
cette contre-offensive aujourd'hui où là
il s'agit d'avancer alors cette armée
ukrainienne est devenue la première
armée d'Europe l'armée la plus puissante
d'Europe en contestablement et si un
jour l'Ukraine rentrait dans l'OTAN ce
serait or les États-Unis ce serait
l'armée la plus puissante européenne
dans cette organisation à cause de nos
de nos aides à nos soutiens militaires
ou ces hommes les Ukrainiens
mobilisation de la nation oui tout à
tiers une détermination une mobilisation
humaine qui est considérable avec
d'ailleurs même d'un point de vue
militaire on voit toute la différence
qu'il y a entre l'armée russe qui reste
quand même une armée de professionnels
volontaires qui est un peu à part coupé
un peu du reste de la nation et cette
armée ukrainienne ou il y a une
multitude de gens qui sont venus de
volontaires de mobiliser qui sont venus
des civils qui sont venus avec leur
vision des choses le rapport leur
rapport technique etc ça a transformé
aujourd'hui pour véritablement la gagner
cette autre offensive parce qu'on a
beaucoup livré malgré tout ça près du
temps il y a eu des paliers mais on ça y
est on est plus au char là on est aux
avions de chasse F16 les Américains vont
les livrer il y a des missiles français
aussi qu'est-ce qui manque encore des
obus voilà pour parler simplement
actuellement c'est à dire que on est on
l'a dit dans une guerre de position en
position c'est à dire que là les
Ukrainiens pour atteindre leur objectif
dont on parle au départ
libérer tout le territoire en superficie
qui reste à libérer c'est l'équivalent
en France de la superficie de
l'Occitanie plus la région Provence
et pour ça il faut qu'ils obtiennent des
grandes victoires il faut qu'ils cassent
le froid il faut qu'ils aillent loin qui
donne des grands coups à cette armée
russe et problème c'est que l'armée
russe pour l'instant sur la défensive
les Russes mènent au score d'une
certaine façon la si la guerre
s'arrêtait aujourd'hui pour dire écoutez
voilà nous on a gagné on a libéré entre
guillemets un certain nombre de
territoires etc et donc il faut les
Ukrainiens doivent passer à l'offensive
mais pour passer l'offensive réussir
cette bataille très difficile dans des
faces des positions retranchées très
retranchées la réalité il faut il faut
beaucoup de puissance de feu il faut
écraser cette défense pour pouvoir et
pour pouvoir pénétrer à l'intérieur il y
a pas de 36 solutions
je voudrais qu'on parle un peu de
l'actualité c'est aussi Erdogan
l'actualité sur l'Ukraine qui a joué un
rôle on le sait très ambigüe sur ce
conflit mais il a autorisé Zelensky à
revenir de Turquie avec des combattants
d'Azov les fameux combattants de cette
usine à sauvetale
ukrainien des plus durs il est pour vous
ça y est du côté de Kiev ou il a trahi
Poutine ou ça reste un jeu d'équilibre
très personnelle
où il essaie de gagner un peu sur
ma position d'hommes indispensable de
tous les camps et maintient des faire au
feu dans tous les camps il maintient le
contact avec la Russie quand tu es
simplement il faut quand même pas
oublier aussi au passage que la Turquie
c'est le pays de l'OTAN qui est en
contact militaire avec la Russie
c'est-à-dire en Syrie il y a des
affrontements avec entre turcs et russes
régulièrement et d'ailleurs ce qui se
passe actuellement n'est peut-être pas
étranger à des événements qu'on n'aura
pas parlé mais qui ont lieu en Syrie
entre turcs et russes donc là j'ai pas
compris il y a eu des combats des
combats il y a eu un certain nombre de
de jambes Turcs qui ont été tués je
crois par des par des Russes
donc on comprend mieux la Turquie
pour le moment oui pour le moment il
donne des signes alkraine il donne des
signes à l'OTAN et il accepte la comment
dire l'entrée de la Suède dans le temps
puisqu'il s'est décisions à l'unanimité
mais certainement en échange de beaucoup
de choses puissant la position sur la
politique kurde en Turquie par exemple
les les opposants
Erdogan voilà qui sont qui vont sortir
de Suède en contrepartie de son
intégration tout petit mot pour terminer
Michel Goya parce qu'on va partir
justement à Vilnius avec Richard Verly
faire l'histoire immédiate d'un conflit
c'est toujours un peu périlleux mais
vous expliquer bien que cette fois-ci
les sources sont très différentes elles
sont très nombreuses et que on voit le
champ de bataille grâce notamment aux
moyens satellitaires grâce au téléphone
portable qui devient une arme de guerre
ça change tout
ça change beaucoup de choses c'est pas
complètement nouveau mais ça change
beaucoup beaucoup de choses et
effectivement on a beaucoup
d'informations dites ouvertes ce qui
permet à n'importe qui en réalité de de
faire des analyses alors ce que le la
plus-value de Jean Jean Lopez ou
moi-même c'est certaines expertises moi
je fais de l'analyse des conflits depuis
19 ans en réalité donc c'est un peu mon
métier de d'analyser les choses avec mon
savoir-faire militaire mais la limite
n'importe qui peut faire faire ce
travail pour peu qu'ils prennent le
temps et qu'il fasse les choses
rigoureusement avec méthode voilà un
ancien chef d'état-major des armées me
disait il y a 15 ans déjà elle me disait
mais en fait n'importe qui actuellement
peut avoir 80% de toutes les
informations que dont je peux disposer
moi chez vetta major des armes merci
beaucoup Michel Goya et pour poursuivre
cet entretien lisez donc l'ours et le
renard co-écris c'est un dialogue
d'ailleurs avec le journaliste Jean
Lopez aux éditions